[Music]
it's a new twist on an old high this is
a ball torch this just gets it done very
quickly and it's packin a heated punch
real clean very pure a lot of people are
feeling that this is the new wave of
cannabis these days stabbed out bad
people daddy uses a blowtorch to get a
super concentrated hit of THC
tetrahydrocannabinol the chemical in
marijuana that makes people hot so along
the sides here you'll see all of our
mothers E&C sells pot in denim a joint
is made up of flowers which has anywhere
from say 13 to the high 20% THC the
extract that we have here today is
around 90% 90% yeah it's great as crack
is to cocaine davin is the pond same
drug just made more potent through
chemical engineering it's just a
concentrate of cannabis it makes the THC
extract inhaled and dabbing marijuana
flowers are rinsed with a solvent in a
lab the butane goes into the tank
through the top washes over the
extraction the material that comes out
of the bottom into the collector which
is right here
what's left behind is a sticky almost
pure blob of THC called butane hash oil
so this is the concentrate itself what
Jake will do is heat up the quartz nail
until it's red-hot
so once he gets it to that point he'll
put this dome on it and the dome
basically captures all of the smoke
that's a DAB recreational use of pot is
now legal in Colorado and Washington
State and that includes dabbing the
marijuana legalization movements message
has always been apostate right on top to
pop but as these striking video show
amateurs of cost explosions while trying
to make butane hash oil in home kitchens
and there have been reports of dabbers
passing out from in ten times that is
some worried about what it all means for
the newly legal marijuana business could
it hurt the industry definitely I've
heard people call it Hera wanna making
an analogy to you know cooking heroin
and stuff like that we absolutely don't
need that we're in the process of taking
an industry from the black market to the
fully legalized and regulated market
let's do it responsibly let's do it
carefully some people are kind of put
off by this
it's scary looking did that hurt the
industry overall I think that the
naysayers and people who are opposed to
marijuana like to use this as ammunition
and they like to say there's blowtorches
and there's fire and there's danger but
marijuana I've never killed that with is
gonna do it the dabbing oil is more
expensive than pot flours a gram of oil
costs fifty dollars versus $15 for a
gram pot but because of the high
concentration a little wax goes a long
way the joke is a dabble do you you know
are you feeling it right now oh yeah of
course
you